well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages so it's time to see what's
making the headlines with mark wallace
chief executive of conservative home and
sonia soda chief leader writer at the
observer they're with us of course right
now from now until just before midnight
welcome to both of you front pages
though let's start with the metro says
the taliban has been holding fake
funerals with coffins draped in western
flags carried through the streets as the
militant group declared victory in
afghanistan
meanwhile the guardian pictures the last
u.s soldier to board a plane leaving
afghanistan marking the nda end of 20
years of u.s involvement
president biden said the end of u.s
involvement in afghanistan is also the
end of attempts to nation build that's
on the front of the telegraph
the daily mirror reports hundreds of
thousands of patients will be offered a
jab to reduce their cholesterol levels
slashing their risk of a heart attack
the financial times says high inflation
in the euro zone is putting pressure on
the european central bank to end its
stimulus policies
to the front of the sun now geronimo is
put down after a legal battle to save
the alpaca after he tested positive for
bovine tb
well mark and sonia are here with their
thoughts and uh not surprising many of
the newspapers still leading with
afghanistan
in a really resonant speech tonight from
joe biden um sonia the daily telegraph
picking up on that as he suggested this
was not just about afghanistan this was
really drawing a line under 20 years of
american foreign policy
absolutely i think what we saw president
joe biden do uh this evening was to
really double down in his defense of the
american actions in afghanistan uh in
recent weeks but also to extend it to
america's wider foreign policy and for
close watchers of joe biden who've been
following his views on foreign policy
you know back back when he was vice
president to president obama
you know this shouldn't come as a
massive surprise because biden has
always been much less interventionist
than obama and in this speech he set out
two clear benchmarks for us intervention
in in wars in the future which is that
it has to be in the u.s national
interest and they have to be clear and
achievable objectives now um if you go
back to america's uh
original action in afghanistan i'm sure
um those involved with it would say that
there were clear objectives
but i think this is biden really
actually being quite trumpian in some
ways in terms of his foreign policy it's
very much america first and he's
basically saying to the rest of the
world look you can't expect us to be the
world's policemen anymore and i think
what that does to the sort of global
order what it means for alliances such
as nato these are all really big
questions i think that the world is
going to have to work through because
historically um and in recent years the
rest of the world has to the us to play
this role um in foreign policy and i
think it's worth saying as well that
biden absolutely doubles down you know
he he he defends the chaotic evacuation
that has left um uh sort of many afghans
who work with the british and u.s and
other foreign governments stranded in
afghanistan it's left you know british
citizens stranded in afghanistan he sort
of doubles down defends that and says it
was the right thing to do but there are
huge questions overhanging america's
policy yes leave or escalate he kept
saying didn't he and also asking
you know what was really a speech for
the american people reminded people why
did we go there in the first place mark
you know we were chasing down terrorists
it morphed into nation building and the
question then at the door of of of the
old hands of george w bush and tony
blair about how it morphed how they were
there so long if it was yemen would we
still be there we have no national
interests beyond why we went originally
i mean it was a fascinating speech
really resetting where he sees america
and where he sees the threat now in the
world of geopolitics
well it was a fascinating and quite
depressing exercise i think in reverse
engineering and an argument and opinion
to fit
the situation he currently finds himself
in but really this is the worst end of
the scale of possible things to learn
about joe biden's policy it means that
what we've seen
in his policy towards afghanistan
precipitous
rushed poorly planned um abandonment of
not just a nation to terrorists and
extremists but of allies um closed poor
communication even within the western
alliance
a great gift to tyrants terrorists any
other group frankly looking to see
how they might be able to get one over
on people who value democracy and
freedom now has a little manifesto a
little blueprint of how to do it and
evidence that it is possible to bore and
bleed the united states into retreat and
he said that isn't just afghanistan
that's my policy towards the whole world
and i think that's an extremely
troubling thing to do all those people
in the last 20 30 years who
whether they're from the far left
yankees go home troops out kind of
campaign whether they're from the right
that kind of trump is not our problem
shrug at the troubles of the world uh
position
they've both now got what they want and
the tragedy is this is a an outcome of a
bipartisan consensus in washington um
for a world without fundamentally a
world without america and i feel we're
only just starting to see the first
people suffering as a result of that and
they won't be the last yeah that is the
big picture stuff isn't it the uh the
first draft of history uh as we look
back on this episode uh we're still in
the manuscript too though aren't we
sonia uh the daily telegraph reporting
that senior british intelligence
officials held secret talks with the
taliban in kabul to seek assurances that
afghanistan will not be used to launch
terrorist attacks on the west the
discussions are understood to have taken
place in the past fortnight in the wake
of the fall of the afghan capital and
the taliban seizure of power and on top
of that
downing street has confirmed tonight
that the prime minister's special
representative for afghan transition
simon gas has traveled to doha and is
meeting senior taliban representatives
to underline the importance of safe
passage this is interesting isn't it and
could it be seen as a first step
in the future to recognition of the
taliban as legitimate government or is
it just a means to an end for now
well i'm not sure about that full step
of recognition of the taliban um as as
sort of as afghans official government
it's hard to see that happening
in the near future but i think it is an
example of the british government
recognizing that it has to work
pragmatically i think once the u.s
decided to withdraw in the manner that
it's done what choice does the british
government have in many ways but to open
up talk to the taliban i think this
story does so sort of put paid to um
what biden tried to say in his speech
which is that there's a complete
separation between you know america's
national interests getting the
terrorists and nation building what his
speech got wrong is that actually you
know nation building but doing what you
come to boston democratic institutions
that can actually be part of building
global security and preventing terrorist
attacks in the future now that clearly
hasn't worked in afghanistan with this
american withdrawal but you know the
fact that got the head of mi6 and and
secret services uh talking not just to
pakistan as you'd expect but to the
taliban about um you know really sort of
trying to set a red line in terms of
that they're not going to get any aid
from the west for example if they do
allow the sorts of terrorism flourish
that we saw you know back with al qaeda
um you know back in 2001.
um i i think this is representative of
of of just a certain amount of
pragmatism really yes real politique as
we used to hear uh to the metro now mark
death to the west uh these are coffins
draped in western flags carried by the
taliban as they mocked the west and
declared victory in afghanistan uh
liberation from their point of view i
would say what do you think
i think unfortunately liberation for the
cat is death for the mouse and
liberation for the taliban is death for
a lot of other people and i think this
front page that image there and the
slogan that's being chanted is just a
taster of that huge fistful of salt
that's going to come with all these
claims about taliban 2.0 the idea that
you could have a taliban your your
promise you know with a cherry on top
not to be a
source of hostile extremism against the
west for that matter the idea that the
taliban can even control all of
afghanistan you know the taliban
themselves as you see very clearly there
um
are islamist extremist violent militant
islamist extremists that's mainly that's
really their thing let's be honest and
they are virulently uh
poisonous and active again against the
west not interest but we've also
literally just seen isis coruscant isis
k
carry out suicide bombing attack against
western troops right under the taliban's
noses now the taliban say that they
weren't um in any way complicit in that
and isis k are their deadly enemies well
in that case it's quite clear that they
cannot guarantee that terrorists acting
against the west will not be operating
in their territory they've just taken
over afghanistan this is already
happening yes we'd seen them earlier
hadn't we the talib fighters
parading in
american uniforms with american weapons
more pictures this evening
sonia of them inspecting some of the
spoils of war some also which had been
destroyed by the americans
demilitarized i think they called it
last night
uh not the fire trucks and not the low
loaders because they want this airport
to to reopen but the the new images are
fascinating uh let's just have a look at
those pictures um lots left behind as
you can see burnt out uh 62 billion
dollars worth of equipment but the
americans learned one lesson i suppose
and tried to destroy some of it at least
uh the metro also um has elements of
this too taliban's new toys they say
with uh one talib fighter taking a
selfie in the cockpit of an afghan air
force plane as well um
there's a lot of kit left behind
there's a lot of kit and as you just
said anna the u.s troops have have sort
of um ruined some of it demilitarized
some of it burned it out etc so it's not
usable but it's a big question mark
about how much is left and usable and
there's huge concerns in the us that um
that that there are working black hawks
the military helicopters um that there
are humvees that there are thousands of
machine guns that can be used so really
a huge military stash some of which may
have been taken out into service like
these images that we're seeing at the
moment but i think there's a lot of
concern in the us um that that much of
it is still still used and and one
uh american opposition politician is
sort of accused biden of leaving the
taliban with more black hawk helicopters
and than 85 percent of countries in the
world
and just a quick word on the guardian
front page it pictures the last u.s
soldier
leaving last night but uh it has word on
the impact of the women the skepticism
uh that you you um talked about earlier
mark on the on and how the taliban will
behave towards people there
yes a heart-rending interview that opens
this piece with a lady in afghanistan
who's been burning her jeans and and
western clothes and it's a reminder that
as much as people talk about that a
really shameful um
era defining image of that last soldier
leaving they talk about this as the end
of the war in afghanistan for for most
afghans this is you know just the start
of a new chapter of this